yeah welcome to this video let's see
quick Bishop f4 the London News system
yeah okay let's do an e6 set up there
are various good ones I made a small
video serious about a year ago 2012
about them the London okay the London
her black a me o his own plexiform so it
is a bit more bit more aggressive now
they don't open they don't often play
night BTW to win this kind of structure
there must be a reason for that the
bishop here that's some subject achill
idea I don't think some let's continue
and try not to waste too much time yeah
it's questionable um actually if the
bishop has a good position when I form
that can easily be a subject to it to
attack with e5
um in comparison rather would prefer to
have be three but should be too played
for example ok lupe 5 all night you 45
yeah I can't play h 6 and g5 that's this
good now if one ive one quite some time
along the way maybe maybe this is a
quite ok you really made lots of fur
bishop moves and Queen d2 z 2 and so on
the main thing that I'm like needs to be
cautious about this the mover c5 make
sure that this is not coming with them
with them was with some deadly effect
Knight f6 them this may be one of those
mc5 moments I could go we five though
why why why not a five or as a to lose
could be but it's also ambitious if it
works out it might be very good for me
threatening to take on g3 and play you
for winning a piece so and if you take
so okay this this shouldn't be too bad
so nice space advantage and maybe I have
night don't really have 95 f 5 X 0 f of
X but I still threaten to take g3 he
needs to do
thing about that maybe poem c5 could be
maybe maybe pawn to c5 could be a way to
to confuse matters what why am I not
winning a piece now not question this
too much probably i really am just
winning the piece
yeah okay you need to have some easy
game once in a while so is he
threatening on on here not really can
attack the Queen first and now should I
how should I play maybe g4 evening
g-form securing this and on before I go
nighty form just 94 m maybe maybe
instantly so if he goes before I can
play c5 even the only thing is um my
somewhat every King am so it's quite
quite loose but he doesn't really have
pieces to a ticket this is the good
thing about next repeats it's a piece
the opponent does not have anymore queen
bee three a thought would be nice now
but it doesn't help so much okay maybe
just he mmm
I take d4 and now it's not it's not
easily winning it looks very nice but
keep it simple come on ok maybe in
purdue he's helping me with some Sam
move no I'm threatening would defo
hey Jim I don't know pinhook t1 is also
clear I mean it it's probably clear for
the comp but need to still make proper
moves look T 1 how do I when he's got
rock edge 5 coming 96 simply probably
just Daniel
and I really need to make sure not to
spend more time
first on do you wanna probably yeah
first here so that I'm even threatening
only three first c4 oh he loves me to
take so probably should should take this
chance they are armed use it take it I
don't know take him he doesn't really
have a check yet and I'm threatening
made with taking I have the checks
covered on g5 and defines this should be
be over now
he has all kinds of mates quindi 7s
Queenie one mate Jack Jack hmm Jack yep
this is also made me all right yeah I
don't know to die all right i think i
did ok after winning the peace this
looks new clue this looks comfortable
and probably he needs to go see five at
some stage maybe maybe see five year
this was some oh that's interesting here
the computer gives c5a sir best move but
already was with a really really
distinct advantage for black yeah it is
not so easy am I mean you're really am
suffering from this is bad bad Bishop
here on g3 I would have played c5 anyway
just to get some activity the IDS c5
take with the United s Bishop f5 if i
take g3 and play for the c6 c5 c6 and
this is certainly the best practical
chance getting some activity going ok
thanks for watching